Chị tay,
có hai người ở đâu.
Mình gì là có anh, anh nhân,
phải bị hải có trò đều.
Phải hiện là ở chỗ này.
Hơn một trong cán bộ,
chính sĩ cùng chống người vụ thuộc đoàn cứ hộ Việt Nam
tất giúp tình kiểm hát nạn dân mắc kẹt ở bàn là Wai Rha.
Saan một tháng bệnh giờ Việt Nam,
chống người vụ phát hiện chính bị chỉ nghĩ có nạn dân.
Đoàn cứ hộ Việt Nam,
phối hợp người dân địa phương,
đo với bẩy bị chỉ,
đưa tắm thi thể ra khỏi đống đồ nát.
Hãy bị chỉ còn lại được bản rao cho chính quyền sở tại tiếp tục sự li.
Thôi trận đồng rất là nặng nè.
rất nhiều các tốt kiện xây dự,
còn lưu lực trên vình rất là mùi hẹn,
chúng tôi,
nhìn kiểu và đe ra,
trên thọ thiếu nạn cứ hộ Wai Phương Trân,
ngang trống,
hình trường,
tuy nhiên,
phải đảm bảo tương đối ăn toàn.
Chau cán bộ,
chính xíc trong qua trên thực hiện nhà bộ.
Chức đó,
chuyến bay khởi hàng từ lội bài,
đêm hai mi tám thẳng sấu,
đưa đoàn cứ hộ Việt Nam tới Vinizuela,
hỗ trợ khác của khọt qua trên tay.
Vinizuela và phần Nam Mi,
các Việt Nam hơn mùi bài ngàn kí lúc mẹ.
Chân đồng rất khác,
hơn bài độ ngày 20,
thẳng sấu tại nước này,
khiến hơn một nạn 40,
40 người thiệt mạng,
hơn bà ngàn người bị thương,
khoảng Nam Mi ngàn người vất tích.